[Music]
604 to our coverage of the coronavirus
two years ago today nevada recruited
recorded its first coronavirus death and
sadly the virus has taken more than 10
thousand lives in our state and still
the pandemic isn't over but it has
changed bianca holman joins us with how
health agencies are now responding to
these new cases bianca good morning
good morning heather good morning
johnson you may remember here at the
health district they used to update us
daily on the numbers regarding coven 19
cases but now that number is just a
weekly update that's what we get now to
inform you all the public
and that's because the numbers are
trending downward so even though there
is a great decline in covid
19 cases health agencies like immunized
nevada and the health district are still
conducting outreach with a new variant
of coven 19 people are still being
infected cell test kits along with coven
19 vaccines booster shots they've all
aided in the decline of the infection
and the new antiviral treatments are the
new frontier of helping to fight the
virus
these kinds of pills are
again just really
a great new tool that we have to be able
to address this pandemic but um just as
just not as widely known to folks in
some cases especially with the pills uh
you have to uh
have been symptomatic for only for five
days or less
so that that's that's a barrier for a
lot of folks as well because they may
not
seek testing services until sometime you
know six days seven days after their
onset of illness
the health district has partnered with
immunized nevada to help serve diverse
populations across the valley from
educational resources on the vaccine to
testing clinics and now they're focusing
on some of the hard hit areas like
89101-89102-89104
again doing more outreach in those zip
codes and so coming up in the next half
hour we're going to talk more about what
the health district and immunized nevada
are doing to combat those myths and of
course those
misinformation that's still out there
and circulating around covet 19.
reporting live bianca holman live local
now